the revelation that emperor palpatine
had a son
and a granddaughter was one of the
biggest moments in the rise of skywalker
in many ways though it posed more
questions than it answered
chief among which just who was the
emperor's mysterious son
the rise of skywalker doesn't explicitly
reveal how palpatine escaped death
although the movie does drop a couple of
hints when kylo visits hexagol for the
first time
he finds supreme leader snoke clones
floating in tubes
later dominic monaghan's character
beaumont kin
offers a handful of theories of his own
suggesting
dark science cloning secrets only the
sift knew
as it turns out beaumont nailed it
palpatine's return relies on all three
like the star wars movie novelizations
ray carson's the rise of skywalker
expanded edition fleshes out the story
that unfolded on the big screen
including the details of palpatine's
return long story short
he used clones during the imperial era
palpatine set up a secret cloning lab on
the planet hexagon
as he fell down the second death star's
reactor shaft in return of the jedi
he used the force to project his
consciousness into a new body
on the far-off civ stronghold a skill
that the novel implies he learned from
his former master
darth plagueis unfortunately things
didn't go
exactly as palpatine had planned the
novel explains
the secret place had not completed its
preparations
the transfer was imperfect and the
cloned body wasn't enough
apparently the dark side takes a big
physical toll on this process
and palpatine's new vessel burned out
pretty quickly so as the new republic
took control of the galaxy
and the first order accumulated power in
the unknown regions
palpatine's sith followers worked
tirelessly to craft the emperor a new
healthier and more permanent body most
of those experiments failed
but one didn't at least not exactly
the novel says one genetic strand cast
lived
thrived even a not quite identical clone
his son still even that body wasn't
perfect
while his clone survived the sith
experiments he couldn't actually wield
the force
and that weakness disgusted palpatine so
instead of using the clone as a host the
former emperor found another use for him
he set his son free so he could continue
his bloodline through more natural
methods
in time palpatine's son met a woman and
had a daughter whose powers met
palpatine standards
after that the sith lord began making
plans to capture rey
and take over her body which obviously
didn't quite pan out
the rise of skywalker novel's
explanation for palpatine's son
dodges a lot of the more difficult
questions about palpatine's family tree
and while it means that rey's father
isn't technically palpatine's son
it's not without president in the star
wars universe
back in the prequel era for example
jango fett treated his own young clone
boba like a son
this is pretty much the same thing or it
is for now at least
the star wars movie novelizations occupy
a liminal space in the franchise's
continuity
and it's entirely possible that future
projects will retcon carson's work
while disney claims that all star wars
material created
after 2014 are a part of the canon
that's not strictly true
and movie novelizations only seem to
count so
long as they're not contradicted by
other higher profile material
for example there's a scene in alan dean
foster's novelization of the force
awakens in which rey and poe meet for
the first time
but that's no longer canon as it's been
superseded by a similar moment at the
end of the last jedi
as such it's possible that carson's
explanation for rey's ancestry won't
survive in the long term
and this has all happened before too in
the years before disney bore star wars
the emperor had a completely different
son who fell victim to the mouse house's
obliteration of the so-called expanded
universe
i felt a great disturbance in the force
as if millions of voices suddenly cried
out in terror
and was suddenly silenced as told in
paul and hollis david's
jedi prince novels the emperor's
original son was triclops
a three-eyed human with considerable
force powers
however to understand his origins you
actually have to go back to the prequel
timeline
where you'll find a woman named sly
moore a force sensitive native of the
planet umbara
moore was one of palpatine's most
trusted advisors not only was she one of
the few people privy to palpatine's
alter ego
darth sidious and his plan to overthrow
the republic but rumors suggested that
they were lovers too
moore gave birth to triclops after
impregnating herself with
force-sensitive dna
she procured from an anonymous source
which is largely implied to be palpatine
on top of that moore is also responsible
for creating triclops's biggest rival
while conducting her bioengineering
experiments sly created a different
three-eyed mutant named trioculus who
tried to take control of the empire
following palpatine's death
of course there's pretty much no chance
that either j.j abrams or his rise of
skywalker co-writer chris tario
so much as glanced at triclops his story
while writing episode 9.
indeed outside of the david's six jedi
prince novels which are aimed squarely
at children
he doesn't make much of an impact on the
old expanded universe
still there are some striking
similarities between triclops and rey's
unnamed father for one neither of them
got along with their dad
after triklops was born palpatine
banished him to the spice mines in
kessel
fearing his power and his pacifist
philosophy both had children too
while imprisoned triclops fell in love
with a former jedi named kendallina
shortly afterwards kendallina gave birth
to a son named ken
who was later whisked away to a secret
jedi city on yavin 4 by an
unknown benefactor like rey ken who is
the titular jedi prince of the david
saga
was an incredibly powerful force user
and like rey
he was devastated when he learned that
he was palpatine's grandson
finally like rey ken ended up rejecting
his birthright
joining the new republic and training
under luke skywalker
so while both kin and triclops are a
little more than footnotes in star wars
vast
sprawling history their legacy lives on
in the rise of skywalker
at least from a certain point of view
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you